No, just like you learn in lesson one where if you have a population and you
take a sample, the sample statistic won't be exactly equal to the population
parameter, most likely. There's a range of values for the mean that any samples
could have. So same with this, if we had some kind of intervention on the
population, so in this case, the Bieber tweeter, and everyone started using
that. Then our best guess is that the mean would be about 40, but it could be
anything around 40. So in other words, there's a range around 40. That the true
population mean would be, if everyone were to use the Bieber Tweeter. Now how
big is this interval? We're going to decide actual numbers that should be
bounding this interval. In order to do that let's think back about this sampling
distribution.